I also like this bread and I'm co-sponsored. The combination of milk and the customary after milk delivery is good.
I can't eat it like Masanami's Suning tea.
But in the
demon world, I don't have a place to buy it in the human world. Buy it in the human world
. Torii in the box.
I'll call you to confirm that he's eating
properly.
Ame
That made it easier to collect a little, but
soon I've accumulated one sheet, but
I want a total of three sheets for use, storage, and after-viewing.
[Music] It's
really so
good, but don't throw away the sticker on the bread bag. It
's cheap and it's
because Japan has a lot of food
expenses.
I'm a wicked Kirby-I'm a wicked Kirby-
I'm trembling in the corner of the park, but I'll protect pecora, not so much an
angelic demon.
May you have a blessing.
I hope they can see it, but me
Hmm,
Seiko and others aren't Tajiri.
Everyone has a distance, and a lot of stickers are gathered.
2 months
I'll paint my neck.
I was crazy when I was there, but when
I got it, nothing happened